soir christian schoettl merci d'être
avec nous en direct sur rt france alors
illustration de ce que la campagne de
vaccination a peut-être de plus ubs
cette décision que vous jugez
unilatérale et inacceptable
mais après presque criminel quoi je veux
dire que 250 vaccin alors que on est
dans une période d'anxiété ou nous nos
personnes les plus affaiblis n'arrivent
pas à trouver de rendez vous c'est
consternant de refuser 150 vaccin alors
que un élu local comme moi et eu un
petit maire vous savez un tout petit
doute qui perd les gens c'est pas des
chiffres cdc des vrais gens avec des
vrais noms et que se dire que celui-là
laissera pas vaccinés ce week-end parce
que on a on a refusé de prendre les
vaccins sous prétexte que ya pas de
secrétariat disponible c'est juste
consternant mais et ça ressemble un peu
à la pétaudière général du traitement de
la vaccination je dois vous la question
chaque fois pour bien qu'on comprenne
quand même parce que ça paraît
effectivement incroyable qu'on se dise
on a 150 doses de vaccins qu'on
n'utilise pas parce que le personnel est
en repos la première question que sont
devenus ces 12 est deuxième on n'a pas
essayé de trouver justement peut-être du
personnel disponible pour traiter ces
doses alors bien heureusement et doses
ont été réparties on parle par le préfet
ailleurs dans le département
et elles vont servir à quelqu'un alors
tant mieux
en réalité il ya une décision
unilatérale de de la présidente de la
communauté de communes qui est dit bah
non là mon personnel est au repos donnez
les à quelqu'un d'autre
ce qui est consternant un je vous le dis
moi je suis ulcérée parce qu' on est
dans un cas de 2 à 6 ans à personne en
danger quoi aujourd'hui clairement vous
attendait une réponse du préfet
quelle serait cette réponse
satisfaisante pour vous écouter pour moi
c'est pas moi qui devrais dire ça en
tant qu'élu mais je pense que c'est très
grave de confier les problèmes
sanitaires à des élus parce que il faut
vraiment un vrai professionnalisme
il faut mettre en oeuvre on a un hôpital
de proximité
ç'aurait dû être lui qui devrait gérer
les vaccinations plutôt que année lui
qui est peut-être pas complètement pris
la mesure de ses fonctions donc c'est
vrai que on aimerait du
professionnalisme on aimerait de la
cohérence et on aimerait que l'état ne
fasse pas un peu du stop and go / sur ce
qui nous arrive c'est un chatel
c'est vrai que c'est pas évident parce
qu'on a entendu beaucoup d'élus en
france se plaindre que l'éthane ne
distribuez pas assez les responsabilités
aux régions territoires et c'est vrai
qu'on voit aussi les quoique ça peut
provoquer quand vous dites vous même ce
sont les élus qui gèrent finalement
alors qui doit gérer ces vaccinations
comme ça fonctionne correctement écouter
on a un système de santé on a des
médecins on a du pharmacien on a des
hôpitaux
c'est l'ours et ils savent faire c'est
leur profession moi quand je vois l'état
qui me dit il faut vous embauche y est
les secrétaires qui prennent des rendez
vous etc
on réinvente l'eau chaude et ça me
paraît extrêmement dangereux ne serait
ce que pour des raisons de clientélisme
tout d'un coup je fais vacciner mes
copains pas les autres enfin on imagine
toutes les dérives possibles
alors que on a assez encore une fois les
pharmaciens les médecins les hôpitaux
sont à disposition c'est leur job et je
pense que il ya rien de pire qu'un élu
qui se déclare compétent s'cusez moi de
cette curiosité mais je le pense très
fort les médecins et les pharmaciens
sont bien dotés
chez vous dans votre commune
aux alentours où là aussi vous remarqué
des couacs
écoutez moi ce que je remarque c'est que
même les personnes de plus de 75 ans dit
fragile n'arrivent pas à trouver de
rendez vous chez nous et donc si vous
regardez sur les sites d'octo libé
autres comment prendre un rendez-vous et
bien vous ne l'avez pas et donc ça n'est
pas possible j'ai en plus année c'est
encore moins possible de refuser 150
doses imaginez que sur notre secteur
side dans quinze jours trois semaines et
il y avait une personne fragile qu'idc
des ducs au vide parce qu'elle a pas eu
de rendez vous on serait on serait des
criminels ouais effectivement merci en
tout cas pour ce témoignage afin de
châtel qui nous montrent effectivement
certains côté ubuesque de cette campagne
de vaccination dans notre pays merci à
vous d'avoir été en direct sur rt france